- [Instructor] In other videos,
we talk about how 10 to 15,000 years ago.
You have the emergence of agriculture
primarily around river valleys,
and it's no surprise that agriculture
first came about around river valleys
because the rivers would flood,
making the soil around them fertile.
They would provide fresh water for crops
and for the people who
would live near them.
Later on, the rivers could be useful for
transporting things like crops,
and so it's not surprising that our
first significant
civilizations also emerged
where the first agriculture emerged.
And our first civilizations we'll see
in ancient Egypt along the Nile.
We will see it in the Indus
Valley along the Indus River.
We'll see it in China along
the Yellow and Yangtze Rivers,
and we'll also see it in Mesopotamia
along the Tigress and Euphrates Rivers.
And what we're gonna focus on in
this video in particular is Mesopotamia.
Now, the word Mesopotamia
literally come from
meso, between, and potamos.
I'm probably not pronouncing
it right, rivers.
So it's the area between
rivers is literally
what Mesopotamia is referring to.
And it's primarily modern day Iraq.
Now the reason why this is
particularly interesting
and it's called the
cradle of civilization,
is not only is it one of or perhaps
the first place that
agriculture developed,
it was at the crossroads of
many other early civilizations.
Notice it's right in between
the Indus Valley civilization here,
and then the ancient Egyptians,
and other civilizations that
were emerging in the area.
And so it's not surprising that this was
a geography that had
significant developments
in terms of technology,
in terms of architecture,
in terms of religion, in terms of writing.
And the first civilization we believe
that emerged in Mesopotamia
are the Sumerians.
Sumerians.
And Sumeria and Sumerians,
it's most associated with
this region right over
here of, let me circle it,
this region right over here
of southern Mesopotamia.
And we currently think
that this civilization
started to emerge around 4000 BCE.
You can see it on this
timeline here in orange,
and they developed things
as basic as the wheel.
The first wheel that was ever discovered
was 3500 BCE in Sumeria.
They're famous for their
architectural structures.
This is a picture here of a ziggurat,
which was at the center of many of
these Sumerian and as we'll
see Mesopotamian cities.
This would require an incredible
amount of labor to produce,
and at the top of these they
had temples to their Gods
and their Gods, they had
a polytheistic religion,
and their Gods took human form.
Also amongst the Sumerians
is where we think
one of the first written
languages developed.
It wasn't the first.
You also have the Egyptian hieroglyphics
and written language emerged amongst
the Harappans and the
Indus Valley civilization
and amongst the Chinese,
but it was one of the first languages.
This right over here is an
example of a cuneiform tablet.
This is a cuneiform tablet
written in the script.
Cuneiform developed by
these ancient Sumerians.
Now, when you talk about Mesopotamia,
you'll talk about Sumerians,
but we'll also talk about other
civilizations that emerge.
In particular, let me write them all down.
You have the Sumerians.
You'll also hear
something called Akkadian,
and as we'll see, Akkadian
is both a language
and an empire that will emerge.
In Mesopotamia over the
roughly 3,000 years BCE,
the two primary languages are Akkadian,
which is considered a Semitic language.
It's related to modern Semitic languages,
like Arabic and Hebrew,
and the reason why
they're called Semitic is
because they're spoken or
they're reported to be spoken
by the descendants of
Shem, who was Noah's son,
in the Hebrew bible.
So, you have the language
Akkadian, which is Semitic,
and then you have the other
language, which is Sumerian.
And as we get into the
third millennium BCE,
the Sumerians start to have a lot of
interaction with Akkadian speaking people,
and Akkadian speaking people
are initially associated
primarily with northern Mesopotamia,
and we believe the first
empire, true empire,
perhaps the first empire in
the world emerged from Acadia,
and it was called the Akkadian Empire.
And if we scroll down over here,
we can see how the Akkadian Empire spread.
We believe that the town of Akkad,
which the Akkadian Empire is named for,
some place in this region right over here,
and the first significant ruler
who really spread that empire was Sargon,
often referred to as Sargon the Great.
And you can see, you can see that
that would have been established around
the middle of the 23rd, or
actually the 24th century BCE.
So around 2350, you
have Sargon establishing
what might be the first
Dynastic empire in the world,
the Akkadian Empire,
and he was able to take control of
both northern and southern Mesopotamia,
so even the Sumerians were under
the control of the Akkadians.
As we'll see over time,
you have a lot of mixing
between the Akkadian language,
the Sumerian language.
Akkadian gets written
in the Cuneiform script,
and starting at around this period,
Sumerian starts to die
as a spoken language
and Akkadian really becomes dominant.
Now, the Akkadians rule for
a little over 100 years,
and then you have several other empires.
It can get confusing.
The way I have structured this timeline is
this top line right over
here is southern Mesopotamia
and this bottom line right over
here is northern Mesopotamia
so this orange shows you where
the Sumerians were reigning.
Some people think that they might
have been the first empire.
This bottom line here, you
can see the Akkadian speakers,
but they were fragmented until
you have Sargon the great
establishing the Akkadian Empire.
Now, you briefly then have a
short-term neo-Sumerian empire,
but the next significant empire
that's often talked about
when associated with Mesopotamia
is the Babylonian Empire.
So Babylon, the Babylonian Empire
was centered at Babylon, right over here,
and it really became a significant empire
under the ruler Hammurabi.
And Hammurabi is perhaps most known,
you can see how he was
able to spread the empire.
The dark brown is what he had with
this empire when he took rule,
and the light brown is what
he was able to spread it to,
so once again, both north and south,
and he's perhaps most famous for
his famous code of Hammurabi,
which is depicted here,
and it wasn't the first written code,
but it was one of the earliest,
and you could view it as
almost a proto-constitution,
and it was based on things
that the Sumerians had before,
but they've even influenced
things like biblical laws,
things that come down to
modern codes of law today.
Now, after the Babylonians,
the other significant empire
that would have control over
significant portions of
Mesopotamia is the Assyrian Empire.
And the Assyrian Empire
is named for their,
I guess you could say their
home base, the town of Assur.
You can see it in this map here,
where we showed the Akkadian Empire.
And both the Babylonians and the Assyrians
were Akkadian speaking,
so at this point now,
and as we get into the
later Assyrian period,
we'll start to have Aramaic be
a more significant language,
another Semitic language,
but as you can see here,
the Assyrian Empire at its peak controlled
much of the modern day Middle East.
Now, the Assyrian Empire
would eventually collapse
in the seventh century BCE,
and it would be taken over
by the Neobabylonian Empire.
I have a map of that right over here,
which also controlled much
of the modern middle east.
Probably the most famous ruler
of the Neobabylonian Empire
was Nebuchadnezzar II from
the Hebrew bible famous for
taking the early Jewish people captive,
the famous Babylonian captivity,
but eventually they would be overthrown,
and they would be overthrown
in the sixth century BCE
by the Persians and Cyrus the Great,
and that'll actually be the end of
the Babylonian captivity
according to biblical accounts.
But the big picture is
that Mesopotamia is called
the cradle of civilization
for a good reason.
Not only do we have these technological
and architectural advancements,
their religion, their writing
has influenced civilization
since, for the last
five, six, 7,000 years.
Well, I'd say definitely
the last 5,000 years,
and a lot of these ideas
that came out of Mesopotamia,
like written codes of
law and the technologies
and all the rest follow with us today.